[Music]
dude I got something you really want to
hear what
a poker story oh okay
let's go
another crazy I mean I just I sat down
for like 30 minutes and then I drew some
guys in and double my money was it was
pretty intense
um
I I don't know why I was like trying to
get more adrenaline but
uh I kind of like Drew I drew some guys
into the hand and then I went all in
with like 200 bucks
I don't know it was 150. it was so total
I had like 300
on the table I think or then it was like
180 something it doesn't matter
uh and and I got some guy to call and so
yeah I double my money up so
walked in with 300 walked out with like
650 or something oh that's not bad
no not bad at all but not bad for 30
minutes but the crazier part was this
guy hit a royal [__] flush no way um
I've never seen one it was so it was so
sick
and it was uh it was Runner
yeah like afterward it was like Runner
Runner so he had like Jack ten of hearts
or something and then there was a queen
and then King Ace came out in hearts uh
and then what's [__] is I guess you
get like a 500 bonus if you just hit
royal flush
and because he didn't swipe his players
card they didn't give it to him no and
the dude was like you know he he needed
that if he would have had that 500 he
would have stayed there a lot longer oh
damn did he like did you see it in his
face like when he when it the Flop came
or whatever was he like
oh my God
uh I mean race
I mean check check
yeah it sucks I don't have anything
[__] didn't get a royal flush at all
I barely got a royal flush [__] so
pissed check
so funny in the middle of a poker room
to just oh my [__] god
sorry
raise five dollars
raise 15.
the dude
[Laughter]
I'm doing Royal raise please
Royal fight you're Roy royally [__]
really [__] because I got a royal
Flash
yeah raise ten dollars
raise six dollars please
how's it how's it been driving in the uh
or the [__] Caravan or in the
Sprinter yeah the Sprinter
it's like sitting on an airplane dude
it's like three to five hour drives
every day and I'm just on my I figured
out I can be on my laptop on a hot spot
oh nice so you work or what yeah
yeah I can get some work done
um
oh that's in the green room I see you're
really doing that
oh yeah yeah come on yeah sorry yeah you
want to like lose your Edge or like yeah
you want to keep the keep the reflexes
up I get it
yeah yeah UTA was like you want to do
meet and greets I'm like no I'm playing
stuff I'm gonna eat into my Starcraft
time
[Laughter]
are you sure I mean you can charge
premium tickets nah
nah yeah I don't do this for the money I
do this to play Starcraft
the old ball and chain you think I'm
here to perform I'm just here to be on
the computer alone
nice that's you should say that on stage
actually
thanks dude yeah that's a good one yeah
that's a really good one
no what was funny about the royal flush
guy though was his body language
afterward he was like
like you know like he hit it and he was
really happy about it
and then when they told him he wasn't
going to get the 500 he was really
trying to
you know
act like he didn't really care
and I said something to him I'm like man
that's I'm like that's [__] up I'm
like I feel for you he's like I don't I
don't care 500 is not [__]
I can feel the pain in your voice there
I don't care bro
I don't [__] care what could that
even get you
like [__] pizzas I don't care about
that
50 burnt tongues yeah
who'd even who could even eat that much
pizza
he he
tried so hard to sell it like he didn't
give a [__] I'm like dude unless you're
unless you're a billionaire 500 is 500
like
I mean it's kind of [__] that the
casino wouldn't just give it to him why
why is that a thing where you have to
swipe your player's card is that like a
bonus for members stupid
I think it's because the money is taken
out of a player driven jackpot so of all
the people who gamble there a piece of
their money gets sliced off the top from
the rake and it goes into a jackpot I
see but like still how many Royal
flushes ever oh yeah I I think it's so
stupid like just [__] pay out a bonus
for it
I mean I mean I guess they must be
pretty common for 500 but it's like just
give it to the guy yeah maybe they are
common how many maybe like one a month
or something
I think more you think so probably at
least yeah in a poker room probably a
couple in a week at least yeah maybe
yeah maybe you're right
the [__] dealer had the funniest
phrase because I drew some guy on on a
heart flush and I and I got him and or I
chase one and I got him but uh
when I turned my cards over he goes
Valentine's Day what does that mean
like like because I had five Hearts nice
yeah I've never I've never heard that
before shut up dude
yeah yo shut the [__] up
oh is it
shut the [__] up dude hey man don't talk
to me
hey just
get my money from that guy and stop
talking you should have uh
yeah you should have said some [__] back
if he got a flush you know those all
Spades or something
yeah David Spade over here
[Laughter]
for sure
he probably would have
or or what if he says it back to me he's
like I'll I'll do the jokes here bud
relax
that's my [__] right
yeah whoa look at David Spade over here
all right elbowing him hey calm down
just play the game this is my Casino
yeah focus on the cards all right
I do the jokes here no no I just
performed at the film or it save it
please you're talking out of turn
small blind big blind thank you seat
nine shut the [__] up
hey seat nine no more jokes how about
that you get a flush of Spades he's like
ah David Spade over here everyone at the
table laughs
I what the [__] I just
uh
you just take my bit bro shut your
little [__] mouth I run this [__]
place you know who I am I'm Hara this is
I'm him
they're going to change the sign from
Harris to him
you know you know how you spell me
h-i-n